[Music]
about women's reproductive rights and
religious liberty I'm joined now by
three of people who know a lot about
this attorney Gloria Allred attorney
Kristen Wagner of the Alliance defending
freedom and professor Steve Vermeil a
law professor at American University and
let me start with you if I could Gloria
Allred what did you make of this
morning's arguments well first of all of
course we we know that we can never tell
how a justice is going to rule based on
the questions that they ask because
sometimes they're asking questions which
are intended to have the answers
influence the vote of another justice
but having said that of course I do
agree with justice Ginsburg's questions
and justice Sotomayor questions which
essentially incorporates Justice
Ginsburg question that didn't the cotton
Congress through the Affordable Care Act
intend to have women be able to be
afforded contraceptive coverage seamless
health coverage and not require them to
have to go out and search for coverage
outside of the health plan that would be
provided by their employer and and I
think their answer would be yes that's
what the intention of Congress was to
make sure that women's contraceptive
coverage would be covered and Kristen
Wagner let me ask you what did you see
out of this as the justices sought to
find a balance of religious liberty and
women's reproductive rights Kristen well
I think what the justices are trying to
do is assume that Congress meant what it
said and what it didn't say in the
statute is that contraceptives must be
covered by everyone and I think the
unique aspect of this particular
argument is that those who argued in
favor of essentially requiring nuns to
dole out birth
they were happy with the Obama
administration's exemptions early on
when they provided exemptions for
churches and others they said oh yes the
administration has the authority to
determine who gets exemptions but now
that the administration has changed they
don't like how the agency is
interpreting those exemptions so I want
to bring this back this isn't about
access to birth control it's about
whether you a statute gives the
authority to an agency to decide these
types of issues and we know they haven't
produced even one woman who hasn't been
able to get coverage that's right that
was very I thought very striking that
they argued that Professor Steve Vermeil
you covered the Supreme Court for years
for The Wall Street Journal tell me what
you saw between the lines here well it
was obviously very lively sometimes
technical argument I think it's hard to
tell from listening to it whether the
court is going to decide this on a
administrative basis did the the Trump
administration and expanding the rule
follow the proper procedures or whether
the court will be more influenced by the
the competing images that we heard of
the effect of the rule that on the one
hand the liberal justices depicting
thousands of women who may not be be
able to get access to contraception and
on the other hand more conservative
justices depicting it as a question of
the religious freedom of employers not
to be forced to provide contraception I
think it's hard to see which way the
court will go and Gloria Allred let me
ask you about Ruth Bader Ginsburg she
was phoning in from her hospital bed
where she was seeking treatment for a
gall bladder issue but seemed to be very
lively and very much in the middle of
this debate yes she did and I have had
the honor and the pleasure of meeting
Justice Ginsburg and having dinner with
her at an event and actually just seeing
her and speaking very briefly to her in
February of this year at an event
we're an award was being made a woman of
leadership award in her honor she is
persistent she is a fighter she is going
to phone in from a hospital bed or
wherever she is because she takes her
duty as a Justice of the Supreme Court
very very seriously and you know she is
my Shiro and the Shiro the hero of so
many millions of women not only in this
United States but also in the world so
I'm proud of her
I I will say that if there is any
discretion of any agency let's assume
there is only for the purpose of
discussion I think the Justice is made
clear that it can't be capricious it
can't be arbitrary it has to be
reasonable so I the argument here is
that what the Trump administration has
expanded in terms of exemptions is not
reasonable and is arbitrary and is
capricious so I do think the you know
even if no woman has said I can't get
birth control that's not the way I think
to decide this because it's clear that
if their health plans do not allow them
to get coverage for contraceptives that
many women will be deprived of their
ability to get contraceptive coverage
because many will not be able to afford
to get it elsewhere
won't be able to find it elsewhere and
are going to have to do the kind of
search for contraceptives that they
should not be required to do and that
was not the intention of the affordable
care act that they had to do at kristen
wiig Iran agree with that were there any
surprises for you in this morning's
arguments well I think the biggest
surprise was just the extreme nature of
the counsel for Pennsylvania and New
Jersey in the sense that he at one
point even argued that only essentially
ministers should be entitled to an
exemption meaning that potentially even
the little sisters I mean we're talking
about nuns and when we want to talk
about reasonableness is it reasonable
that we would force Catholic nuns to
dole out birth control another petition
that's pending before the court has to
do with March for life which is a
pro-life organization that brings
millions to Washington DC each year they
would be required a pro-life
organization whose entire purpose is to
promote pro-life causes to potentially
use their money spend their money for
their employees to have a board of a
ssin coverage under their policies when
they can go and get that from other
places so this theoretical stuff of the
slippery slope when women can't find
birth control we're smart birth control
is easily accessible we can get it in
our doorstop overnight and the
government itself has admitted in this
case that there are many other means
that they can use to ensure women have
seamless coverage get their birth
control and their abortifacients without
forcing religious objectors to be
complicit in it and Kristen Wagner do
you think the courts going to take this
on head-on or just find a way to do a
technical ruling that will not take a
bigger issue in consideration oh you
know in our experience before the court
you never know exactly what it will do
and this is the sixth case in the last
eight years over this particular statute
so I think it's difficult to say I was
interested in justice Thomas's questions
related to standing meaning whether the
state's actually should be able to
present this claim and also this is a
little different than previous cases
involving what discretion does an agency
have in determining exemptions so I
think it could could be a little bit of
a boring decision in the sense of it
might focus on administrative discretion
and those kinds of things but it's
certainly important as you see how it
plays out and affects real people and
see vermigli you've sent through so many
court hearings over the years as a
lawyer and as a journalist was this any
different to see it this way with the
questions we certainly Justice Thomas
rarely asked her question he asked
plenty of questions today
I mean it's fascinating to get to hear
it live and not be in the courtroom
that's an unusual experience just as
Thomas I think probably felt that if the
Chief Justice was actually going to call
on him by name it was it was not a
situation in which you simply wanted to
say I pass and so he felt that he should
participate I wanted to just note one
thing which I think we heard most
clearly from Justice Breyer and that is
the courts frustration that this issue
hasn't been settled the court had this
case in 2016 it seemed to be deadlocked
at the time it is a ruling in which it
basically said let's send this back to
the lower courts though that the
government and the various parties and
the states and the courts can all figure
out a solution and Justice Breyer seemed
somewhat frustrated that here we are
again and still not clear what the
solution is that's right and Gloria all
we heard that from Pam you said why
can't we work this out is there a way to
balance these issues the legislating and
women's reproductive rights well I mean
I think that Justice Ginsburg was
essentially suggesting that you know
women also have to have their views
respected there should be tolerance for
their views you know not everybody
agrees with the anti-choice the an anti
contraceptive views of the so-called
pro-life religious groups there are many
people whose religions do not require
that that they give up contraceptives or
do not have access to contraceptives so
what about respect and tolerance for the
religious views of those who do not
agree for example with the views of the
Little Sisters of the Poor who are
Catholic and we try to respect
everyone's religious views in the United
States and not just the views of one
religion
right well this would be a closely
watched decision we've got about 20
seconds left and this already care to
predict the outcome no I can't predict
the outcome but I hope it's an outcome
and no one yeah all right well my thanks
to you Gloria Allred Kristin Wagoner
thank you so much appreciate you being
here
and professor Steve Vermeil from
American University Law School thank you
all for being here a fascinating morning
an hour and 40 minutes of contentious
debate back and forth
I'm Brian Ross thanks for joining us
have a good day
[Music]